when are you going to leave it you've
told me time and time again you're going
to leave it when
you imagine shut up shut up
shut up you're so boring
when do you leave i'll leave when i
leave when i'm ready yeah yeah change
your
locks if you don't want me to change the
locks if you do sharp
[Music]
all right all right all right
what's good guys hope you are well
um
yeah man we're here again
i didn't know i felt like i knew i was
going to see you guys i hope you're
welcome
yeah yeah i had no idea what i was gonna
say yeah um so guys you already know the
drill
give the episode a tiny little pause
head on over to patreon.com forward
slash shits and gigs to catch up on over
two years worth of episodes that we did
in the dark behind the wall
um
uncensored unedited
yeah no ads all that good stuff and we
post on there every single thursday so
patreon.com forsyth shits and gig it's
gonna cost you three pound a month tempe
a day run the p man you already know
what it is join the community over there
um guys if you're listening on spotify
apple podcast google podcast wherever
you listen to your podcast make sure you
please please please leave us a nice
review give us a star rating subscribe
to the show help us kind of get the cult
numbers up yeah ma'am um
and yeah it's looking good so far guys
so keep it all coming um
white robes and uses is the uniform you
know the vibes you already know the
vibes you know what it is and um
if you are gosh i've got brain fog today
i've got brain fog guys i'm gonna i'm
gonna warm up i'm gonna get into it um
if you're
watching on youtube you already know
there should be things being chirped in
the comments as we speak as we speak as
we speak live action chirps in um in
preparation for the live show on the
23rd of january shameless plug make sure
you're there
london you already know what it is
yeah come on if you're thinking what's
this live show what they're talking
about go to last week's episode find out
there
go to the instagram all the details are
there you know the vibes you know the
vibes you know the drill um
and uh yeah guys try to sing in the
comments like and subscribe and please
guys help us with the algorithm help us
keep grabbing we recently smashed
through 100k subscribers on youtube guys
so thank you so much thank you so much
that was sick uh that's insane yeah
that's been a big goal of us for a long
time since day one since literally
literally since day one it was one of
the first things on our goals list yeah
it was wow
so youtube we're expecting that plaque
sooner yeah i want that plaque still
we're there now we're accredited for the
plaque so you know run the plaque please
we want it smack bang in the middle yeah
um so yeah guys
and uh we've got a very special episode
for you today guys we've got a special
guest coming in first time in a long
time first time in a long time you guys
have been asking for a guest for a while
now um
so she'll be here with us in a bit her
name is beau and she's going to talk to
us all things only fans you know your
boys love to talk about only fantasy you
already know we've been deciding whether
we're going to spread the cheeks for the
mandem um for a shameless buck
and hopefully she can come in and sway
the odds yeah yeah hopefully she can
come in and let us know whether it's
worth yeah jumping on yeah um
and if yeah if it's easily done um so
guys she'll be here in a little bit so
look forward to that but in the meantime
you are here with the core crew your
boys j money and fire lord fuegs are
here
to hit you with a fun fact let's go fun
fact of the day guys in japan over 50
percent of men give all their money to
give all their money their earned to
their wives and get an allowance back
monthly that's actually fine i actually
knew that fact really i knew that
already really yeah i have never heard
of that or knew that was a thing bro
yeah i somewhat think that's smart
sometimes who said it who tweeted it the
other day we spoke about it before it
was uh lethal bizzle when he said men
earn the money women chop it up
maybe i can't remember he tweeted a
couple months ago we spoke about it but
uh and he got a little bit of flack for
it as like a sexist comment but um
yeah bro i don't know why that's the
case but yeah i've heard that that is
literally the thing mad man just go out
there work get the p run it to the
misses so let me know how much i'm
allowed to have
mad it must i can't be trusted because
it must bring
it clearly brings a form of financial
stability to to the household oh yeah
yeah yeah because
if i'm bringing in 5k a month on a whim
i'm
splurging unnecessarily yeah that's the
thing it's a necessity it's a it's a
very it's a very nice dynamic in terms
of
it works if you think about like yeah
like you said logistically especially if
it's like a classic thing where the guy
works and the woman doesn't it would
make sense for her to be in charge of
who gets what yeah because if i'm out
breaking my back for 10 11 12 hours a
day 40 hours a week whatever i'm doing
and then once i get paid for that i want
to treat myself yeah i've worked hard of
course i want to treat myself of course
yeah this is foolishness yeah i can pay
the bills and i can pay the mortgage but
after that i want to treat myself so it
makes sense to give it to someone who's
yeah
not been through that struggle run me
the p so they can think wisely yeah yeah
yeah they're not emotionally attached to
this yeah you've been breaking your
balls for this yeah yeah you've been
having man spit in your face you've been
having your boss tell you ain't [ __ ]
you've been having to deal with
[ __ ] in the office all week yeah
once you get paid
you want a splash so it makes sense here
logistically so they don't go bankrupt
um
to to chop it up to the wife but yeah
it's [ __ ]
interesting that is like a that's a
cultural noise that's insane man it must
like it must help a lot clearly more
than 50 i said more than 50 percent
china's a big country japan japan sorry
my bad people racist
[Music]
um yeah they do they do everything
different over there true
very very yeah they do it different and
then not necessarily wrong hmm
but yeah that's um that's the fun fact
that's the fun fact of the day
let us know what you think about that
would you would you ever do that mandem
would you ever run your p to your misses
to let her handle her order no matter
give you give you pocket money
essentially yeah no man's saying just
yeah style pride there yeah the pride in
the west no
no one's running all their pride in the
west
no one's running all their p to their
misses to get an allowance back they're
just not doing it
they'll be the face of twitter ah
i gave my man 40 bucks today
yeah that's the thing the thing is as
well
that's actually the thing it's not even
the guy not wanting to do it is he does
not want to risk the flack
from the woman just available on there
like my little boo-boo
i gave him an extra 20 quid because he
was nice to me this because he was nice
today he said the sandwich the sandwich
truck's coming around the work estate so
i gave him an extra tenner [ __ ] cute
little thing [ __ ] made his toes cut his
face lit up i told himself to get
himself nice nah
[ __ ] you yeah yeah yeah women can't be
trusted we'll be the jest of everything
yeah we haven't been trusting we've been
coming trusting can't be trusted
so that's the areas what they're
basically saying in japan is they trust
their relationships more
they're not going to go online and
wholeheartedly [ __ ] around for sure yeah
take advantage of man
they will do that here fair enough
but guys
now that we're warmed up and settled in
yeah mom let's spin the cameras around
let's get bow in and um
hope you enjoy our company see you in a
bit see you in a bit
right guys um
we have a special guest in today
um
probably the first well definitely the
first one in this studio
first in a while as well first in a
while first in a very very long time and
it is our pleasure
to introduce
beau
hi hi boy
thank you for coming on sir if you like
to just you know give the people a
background about yourself who you are
what you're about what you do why you're
here and then yeah yeah so um
i'm in the adult industry i did
webcoming for nearly seven years
um and now i do only fans and like
content creating okay talk that kind of
thing okay cool yeah before we get into
a deep dive of all that because
obviously that's what the juicy content
is for yeah we're gonna do a little
icebreaker just the relax your best yeah
it's gonna do a little icebreaker just
to calm your nerves just a couple
questions
you know just uh makes you feel relaxed
cool
if you could pick one song to sing
karaoke without forgetting any lyrics
what would it be that's good question oh
my gosh we can spin it back as well if
you don't you can't think of an answer
now we can run it back
yeah i don't know there's no song at the
moment that you know the song from head
to toe
no i'm one of them people that
gets the words really wrong and
obviously oh wow
[Laughter]
okay right now you can't cheat yeah have
you got your phone on you yeah okay okay
i want you to show me your top three
emojis
okay get my phone
okay
let's see if you ain't got a laughing
one in them i'm gonna be concerned okay
so it is
what's mine actually is it the the top
three the one in a like they're in a row
yeah so one two three oh so
i've got the laughing face
then i've got the upside down smile yeah
and then i've got the
the smoke
we'll address that later
that's funny
yeah i didn't actually expect it to be
dangerous that's hilarious that's
hilarious cool question three zombie
apocalypse right i'm allowed to say
where you're from oh yeah yeah yeah
you're from near about lee's right yeah
so let's say it happens in and around
these obviously you're familiar with
that area yeah you know what's happening
in the area you've got three options you
can have a shotgun you've only got 36
rounds but you have the chance of
finding more rounds but remember zombie
apocalypse other people might have guns
as well other people might be finding
ammo or a baseball bat
or a katana which is a samurai sword
what are you picking
oh my gosh um
not the gun brother where did you find
these questions yeah i would just go
with the gun because i would
i don't think i'd have a good enough
swing so you know like a a bat yeah yeah
yeah so you think the gun the easy
option yeah well it's probably not the
easy option but the one i probably go
for
what happens when you run out of the 36
rounds
hope for the best
that's honest fair that is honest i
think i just hope for the best okay
the fav what's your favorite item that
you've bought this year and why
my car okay yeah just because i love
cars and
i've just got that discovery
um and yeah i've just wanted that car
for a long time really i love it yeah
that's cool and i've got two massive
dogs so okay it helps yeah fair enough
yeah and it snows a lot in leads so
cool uh last but not least who is your
celebrity crush
oh um
who is my celebrity crush someone asked
me this yesterday as well and i didn't
really have an answer so i didn't answer
what was the first one what was the
first someone didn't answer who was the
first person that came to mind because
you've been asked this before like you
said yeah someone must come to mind when
that question is asked
probably the guy from 365 days
i don't know his name i know exactly the
biggest spanish bride yeah someone mum
wrote like yeah
mike it's like mikhail and like i
thought that's so good
the main guy let me let me put it i'm
glad that just gets sucked off he just
gets sucked off for the whole film
oh yeah he's like off anyone yeah yeah
he's a man's man right
cool so
got to mind the [ __ ] right so
that was so hard
my girlfriend started only fast two
months ago
and after one month she only had one
follower which was me
she was really upset and i felt bad for
her i decided to create multiple
accounts and subscribe to her
you never
no he never bro
i decided to create multiple accounts
and subscribe to her so she would be
happier and more encouraged to carry on
with this journey
recently over the past few weeks she's
been messaging one of my accounts
which uses a very handsome male profile
picture and she's been hinting about
meeting up with him no she has not bro
the [ __ ] betrayal
the absolute [ __ ] cheek of it [ __ ]
i don't know what to do right now yeah
do i tell her the truth about what i'm
doing or continue pretending to be this
guy to not upset her
she has mentioned flying out to meet up
with this guy
i think her heart would be broken if i
told her
[ __ ] her [ __ ]
literally [ __ ] her [ __ ] her heart i'm
telling her on the spot it's me
jermaine you've been moaning about it me
yeah oh i'm telling her day one
i'm saying that all right anyway so but
what are your thoughts what should we do
well [ __ ] you know i don't know because
i if i was
i don't know i would just probably
delete the account and just if you were
him
yeah i just obviously delete the account
and then if she starts acting different
with him i'd be like
i know why you're acting different than
this i don't know because she'll
if you know she's going to cheat on you
then
yeah i don't know well you don't want to
do an only fans anyway because you won't
want him potentially meeting up with
subscribers
i don't know
i just
it's hard because
he's the he's the guy isn't he so i'm
not in his it's from a guy's perspective
but
but how would you feel
if you jumped up if you started your
only fans today right a fresh one and
you've only got one subscriber
after a month yeah
and it was literally your boyfriend
so she knew it was her boyfriend i'm
assuming she knew the ones yeah she knew
that one more yeah not the the aliases
yeah she knew he was the original
right so what
i'm a bit confused here so cool right
you might have gone right let's just say
something restart that question yeah
yeah yeah yeah you've just started my
point of view from the girl or the guy
both okay yeah yeah we'll start with the
girl right so to be fair the point of
view from the girls obviously she's
tragic
so
she's tragic that's literally that's the
point of you yeah she's a failure
but okay cool so you've just started
your only fans i'm your boyfriend i
subscribe to your own fans to support
you it's been how many months did you
say it's been two months three months
yeah and you've been posting content
yeah weekly content and it's still just
me yeah yeah and then one like one
comment vote
nah
i'm deleting the whole thing so after
two months you're pissed off you're
upset and i feel bad so i create five
other accounts and i pay for them all
myself yeah do you think you've got five
new subscribers now you think you've got
six total one including me yeah one of
them is a banging guy
and you just start messaging messaging
him yeah and obviously it's me the whole
time
so
from your point of view
yeah that's the the girl's point of view
is irrelevant
[Music]
she's tragic and she's a cheat that's
literally her point of view yeah okay
sorry guys we just had a couple of
technical difficulties so we had a
little
switch around with the camera
um
but yeah so did you say i asked you yeah
what are you doing continuing the
relationship yeah so
no i don't know i'm not continuing
relation i'm just going to try and
digress how i'm going to handle the
situation so point one is your delete in
the account point one deleting the first
account like beau said i think that's a
good idea just to obviously that has to
that's to be done and dusted you can't
let that continue
we can't let the chirps in can't
continue yeah yeah um then i would leave
the other four as bait if
if
she
tries to like start flirting with with
another person
or if she starts to act differently
towards me like you said once i've
deleted the account we'd have to have a
sit down i'll be i'll i'll probably sit
down down and be like let's say you're
the girl right
babe
yeah listen
i know you've started this only fans
career and and it's flourishing clearly
it's it's clearly flourishing but
i've got some bad news
um
do you remember jermaine
that was me
at that point your draw will drop right
okay yeah
so i need you to tell me
one
why you thought it was okay
to start this illustrious career
and tried chirps and next month
potentially
wanting to fly out to meet quote-unquote
germain with my money with my money
by the way all these other four guys
that are on your account that's me too
yeah yeah just to skip to the end let me
just skip to the end they're all me yeah
i was your first one and i'm clearly
your last one yeah
tell me why
okay
well at that point i don't think i'd
have anything to say i'd be more if i
said i'd just take my bag and go
i don't mean what can you say like i
literally would probably grab my stuff
if i like i know even if it was my house
and i'd just go
you'd pack your stuff out of your own
yard and leave yeah because i'd be that
mortified i think
she has no choice
i mean what can you say there's
literally nothing you can say you can't
you can never justify actually not even
buy it you just have to be like okay
about go now
yeah 100 that's what you literally have
to get
this is not even a game yeah just leave
like out i'm not even doing this whole
polite chat that you just said i'm not
doing it first thing i'm doing i'm
changing the jermaine's profile picture
to me
that's the first thing
yeah because now she needs to face me
i'm not bringing the table to her she
needs to find her chest i'm not saying
anything
i'm just changing the picture to me
yeah i'm going to carry on her world
would rock yeah 100 sweats i will leave
her i'll do it while i'm at work as well
so she can't even see anything straight
away yeah she's got time to think yeah i
put my phone on do not disturb i'm
changing the profile picture to me and
she can sit with that
as long as she wants no that's hilarious
that's a very good answer
and i'm not going to say anything
whoever speaks first loses that's chaos
i love it yeah yeah i love it yeah 100
that's it and then i'm just dumping her
when she confronts me yeah yeah yeah um
as soon as she's
i'm expecting when she confronts me her
bag is packed
before you get to yard yeah 100 bags are
ready yeah if you get me at the door
when you and at least have the courtesy
to say goodbye but after that we're done
there's nothing else to be said like
you're actually taking the [ __ ] piss
you've actually got a man that's
actually willing to spend his own money
even when you just thought it was just
me yeah like even before i created all
this other [ __ ] true i was still the
right or died he's trying to build you
up and then you're just leveraging that
to chirps next man
well i'm stuck here paying my own money
for this foolishness and no one wants
you literally no one wants you she must
have been posting trash
she must've been close and absolutely
trash anyway um anyway yeah let's talk
about your career let's yeah so
um
what made you switch from cam garden to
only fans
um i like content stuff yeah mainly
because
i mean i was kind of
okay for one
webcam sites take 65 of all your money
really wow do they actually i would
never have guessed they take 65
in your tips 65 65 they take that's
[ __ ] oh and that's just across the
board yeah yeah that's [ __ ] wow and
i did that for six years so the amount
of money like just they're just making
for none wow phenomenal phenomenal
money
um yeah so they took 65 and then i had
like a couple of friends that did only
fans and i had only fans in the
background but i didn't really post
anything on it because you're not even
allowed to say on like the webcam site
follow me on early fans because then you
could lose your webcam of course so
and then when you're on webcam like you
just have to stay
in that room in them four walls
obviously only fans you can go on
holiday you can just have your friends
true true yeah so yeah and obviously
it's just a lot more freer you know to
do what you want and
luckily like some of my webcam people
kind of followed me there
um so yeah it just worked out for me and
i would say it's better money i mean
they take twenty percent webcam takes 60
pounds
much more about money yeah
and yes i've just kind of never looked
back i stopped in january i think the
cam the cam yeah for good i was like
winding down from last year and then i
stopped in january so
i really only had my only fans properly
going since last july i'd say and have
you seen a massive transition in like
your
your everyday life from camp to
only fans are you like recognized a lot
more do you get people stopping on the
street do you how does how does it yeah
no no one really like approaches me like
obviously people in my area now like
when i was on webcam only my close
friends and family knew yeah
um and then i was like if i'm gonna do
any fans i need socials and then that's
when i made socials and some people was
like whoa i never knew you did that for
all that time um i'm fascinated though a
lot of my questions just
premise a lot of my questions are going
to be money related okay i'm fascinated
behind the business yeah yeah yeah i'm
fascinated um so
what in terms of like from when you were
cam gunning because obviously now you
said like when you move over to only
fans it's more like social seeing yeah
and then i'm assuming it's much easier
like you said you do like tic tocs and
stuff
i reckon
the conversion's like pretty decent yeah
yeah that's how i get all my yeah yeah
so from tick tock to yeah
all right six so
how was it on like when you were cam
guardian and stuff how did you like
get new people so it was advertised on
can i say the name like whether yeah
like
yes
when you go on pawn up
and it says like
chat to webcam girls now there's girls
waiting live it would be like our
streams
all the time
on
um
yeah that's how and they had a really
good like traffic so there was always
people there but then you have to sit on
freecam like you have to sit it's like
you're in like um a chat room they see
you for free until then they take you
into a private chat and then you charge
by the minute by the minute by the
minute
your discretion
yeah so yeah i charged um ten dollars a
minute but i obviously
but i obviously lost 65 percent of that
oh [ __ ] yeah
that's so much money four pound fifty
yeah that's a mug thing yeah yeah yeah
not even 50 50. wow yeah wow very
[ __ ] enough yeah i'm not surprised
you move though so yeah i can't believe
i did it for six years though six is a
long time
but then again only fans wasn't popping
until how many years
ago it's only been like popular popular
for like three four years maybe yeah i
feel like since lockdown it was like
frowned upon when i did it and then
lockdown came and it just of course it
boosted the whole thing so i'm not
surprised at all i'm not surprised at
all
i only found like 20
yes 20
and what would you say you're are you do
you want to talk about like your biggest
payouts and stuff yeah i can well i have
i have
a guy that has always paid me really
well like he'd
like messaged me on the morning and send
me money for coffee but it's only like
750 dollars
it's outrageous
it actually is my friend that's
offensive yeah i know how much a coffee
is does he know how much coffee is in
england that's a flex 750 yeah and
that's all that's just regular yeah and
he doesn't want anything for it like he
doesn't even want to see a coffee in my
hand like
he doesn't even want a picture to prove
i've had coffee he just wants to feel
good for the day that's his good day for
the day yeah
that's fascinating wow this is what i'm
saying bro i'm not joking
for 7.50 a day i'll spread my cheeks
would you
maybe not just for that but that's like
if that was like a certified like
minimum payout yeah if you for you to
get only fans at 750 a day and then
everything else is just on time am i
spreading magic just for the my man no
you're just that's the post the post but
obviously he's not asking for anything
oh yeah true so these are just your
public
schools 7 50 a day yeah it's pretty much
a day a day yeah yeah yeah spread my
cheeks i mean it's not yeah he don't say
it every day but i mean just that he'll
be like go get yourself coffee oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] he's loyal
that's really cool he's from america
though so yeah um do you have any like
main subscribers that you'd be thinking
if i lost these i'll be [ __ ] him yeah
yeah yeah true
fair
yeah yeah yeah
obviously i have a few that are like
very good
like that i mean he's i had him he's
probably my best ever because i mean
he sends that and he doesn't want
anything for it in return yeah yeah even
if you have a good one they want you to
make full-on videos
um
but yeah so he's probably my best friend
have you had any um sexy female requests
from women yeah
no but
i have guys that pretend to be women
interesting uh
just for you or they do that they'll
just pretend that they're a woman to see
if they can get more out of it or um
you just well from my webcam days
you'll know when they come on they'll
say hi my name's claire for example
and you just already know it's a a guy
and then they'll go on what's
but then they'll go on webcam and
they're dressed in full
lingerie fascinating and then they want
you to talk to them as if you're doing
it to a woman oh
my that's so fascinating yeah listen to
me james yeah i can't be a webcam girl
right
and i'm talking thinking i'm talking to
a girl and then you pop up in lingerie
yeah i would die i'll break character
and me bro because i'm telling you don't
react that's the first thing i say
as soon as the camera falls on [ __ ]
react don't spoil this that you
desperately react
listen to me james yeah yeah that's
actually a good question actually it
um obviously can go on probably more now
than 20 fans but is there situations
where like you have to like really like
keep coming into character like stuff
like that yeah is it like frowned upon
to like
obviously laugh in this round but like
yeah you don't want to lie do they want
you to like be like oh wow or do they
expect you to just like straight face it
and then this i was expecting this
yeah i think so like sometimes so it's
i feel like everything is webcam based
like i'm discussing because it's like
they're they're there yeah yeah true
true um
so there what there's i feel like
there's been multiple occasions where
i'd have to like so i'd like sit up from
the cam so my face was hidden because
i'd be like
holding it in because like for example
like i used to have this one guy and he
was on all the time and he'd like giggle
like really awkwardly giggle oh wow like
say i'm shy and do like hee hee hee oh
oh god
that would break me suspend us
yeah you can't break character yes
just carry on doing what i'm doing
[Music]
but then i felt bad like i'd say like
just go off cam it's fine
i'm like because i felt like is he this
uncomfortable i don't want to make him
uncomfortable but he was adamant he
wanted to stay on webcam
damn fascinating yeah cool right so
moving mel over to the right so i
actually have no idea in terms of like
the interworkings of only fans i have no
idea
um so
how does it work right so is it
is there a set um
subscriber rate or is it like tears
so yeah like do you mean she's all to
pay one price so just to be a subscriber
is it just one
price yeah okay cool um and then yeah
what's like
extra incentives from there so like you
pay a price to get onto the only fans
and then if you wanted like a custom
video if you wanted to video call sex to
set phone sex there's all them options
there
um and then that's where you make your
money like the subscription price is
only seven dollars so that's really
nothing yeah yeah so when people think
yeah i think the misconception is people
think oh my god you're doing all that
and you're seven dollars
but it's that's not really it it's like
when you're selling things on top of
that that's where you get your money
and then there's the guys that are into
like finding and stuff like that so
that's obviously a good amount of money
and
other fetishes i know a trick that that
does really i think i've told you about
this before it was a while ago yeah
and it paid well pays well and you set
your own rates for all that stuff yeah
yeah and for the subscriber price as
well yeah yeah you can do all that
yourself it's like you completely manage
it how you want to manage it so it's
crazy oh that's so juicy are you not
going down pat you got lucky yeah that
is really juicy okay so how much time
like do you have to
do you find yourself doing stuff like
every day so yeah i'd say on average i
do like 16 hours a day seven days rick
really yeah ex okay talk talk us through
your day what's the day
[Music]
in the life of both this is your time so
i have to do like tick tock you have to
do like two or three a day and then i
have like four to five tick tock
accounts running because i get banned
all the time you can imagine
but it's really frustrating because
girls with smaller boobs get away with
so much fun i never thought of that yeah
never thought of that i have to post
like certain times and across like four
or five accounts you post on twitter
um i do now and again but i've never
really pushed my twitter twitter so i
feel like twitter's just no fifa thought
twitter is better
um i've got two accounts on at the
minute on tick tock that are on final
warning so i'm just
um so yeah i've got like five of them
and obviously that takes time of course
and then
i obviously have to be posting
constantly on many fans yeah like you
don't put a post on in the morning
people are like where the [ __ ] are you
yeah oh so it's like every single day
you have to post on it oh yeah like make
new content i make new content like
multiple times a week then you've got
customs then you've got phone calls
video calls
in terms of the phone calls how does
that work because i'm assuming you don't
just give out your number no so it's
just like skype phone calls so it's like
the email address okay okay
um so yeah
and it's just crazy because then you
have like you'll have constant messages
to reply to so and obviously some of my
subscribers are american so i literally
stay on that account till like two three
a.m
and then i have like five hours sleep
and then i'm back on it
that and you can't have a day off really
that's insane yeah that's actually
torturous
that's actually torturous wow i have no
idea i thought your man was just
literally
yeah i think people think you like post
picture and then that's it yeah that's a
serious misconception yeah yeah wow
because per subscriber if i'm charging
seven dollars i think i get five dollars
sixty per subscriber so if i just left
it at that
it wouldn't do very well yeah yeah and
then you've got obviously try and retain
them subscribers and keep them month
after month then
16 hours a day seven days a week yeah i
would have given up by now oh would have
made it one month i would probably
promise you i wouldn't have made it rack
it up in a month
the whole thing yeah that's insane yeah
you've got um you've got dedication yeah
what's the like um
what's that like typical like average
like retention and stuff do you get like
um
loads of people sign up in one month and
then just like most of them drop off or
is it like yeah it depends i mean i a
lot of girls do like share for share and
they'll share each other's account but
i've never really done that where i've
shared other girls in my account and i
tried it once or twice and i wasn't
getting the like subscribers i wanted
so it's usually when like a tic toc
video goes viral i'll get like an influx
and then
you need like i'd say at least two or
three virals a month to keep it going
because some people just come for a look
like just come for a nosey and see
what's what yeah and then you obviously
get some people that don't want to spend
anything other than the subscription
price so they'll drop off yeah so it is
constantly you've like got to constantly
market yourself and be like
i am here because there's so many
there's like thousands yeah yeah yeah i
was gonna say you need to like try and
always think a new thing so damn it's
crazy
and how many have you done any shots
today
before you come to the studio not today
no
i literally put a message out saying
like i'm traveling today so you have to
just
you're going to have to wait how hungry
are these guys oliver twist
yeah i want more yeah i've woken up i've
been i've been awake for 15 minutes i've
been waiting and i haven't seen tears
like what's going on yeah no yeah so
like i'll be like like obviously i'll
reply to messages all the way here i'll
reply to all my messages all the way
back i'll probably edit tick tocks edit
videos wow
do you think it's like um
can you see yourself like going at this
rate for like a long because obviously
the the more popular you get the like
yeah you know the worse it will get no
so do you think you can like manage it
or yeah i mean
at first when i had a video go viral in
like february and i was overwhelmed like
i was like i i genuinely didn't know
what to do
um because i hadn't had like that influx
yet of subscribers um
but yeah i mean it's just like my
day-to-day life now that's like i'm
going on holiday next week and i can
just take my work with me yeah like real
really like i can just do it on my phone
if i had to i don't just use my phone
but
yeah i mean i have three different
phones i have a laptop i have an ipad i
have a mac i have different cameras
because on tiktok as well you can get
banned on the device so i have to like
different devices really can you oh my
goodness yeah so i have like three
different iphones at the minute go
because like the ip address or something
it must be yeah i've even tried like vpn
i've tried everything but apparently
they can device block you wow i'm on
three different devices at the minute so
i'm like and then i've got my snapchat
yeah
yo yeah
yo you deserve all the bags i'm not
going to like you
what are you off chicks and mandem as
well you deserve
in orders head i was thinking post like
once a week
no i'm never joking i thought like a big
one i would i would assume it would be
like a post every day but not 16 hours a
day every single year yeah i've never
thought about like the
getting banned on tick-tock because even
when we have a video taken off tick-tock
i'm scrubbing yeah yeah i am screwing
and that's just like it could be any
run-of-the-mill video and i'm pissed off
yeah um so yeah to be running
yes i would oh that's dedication that is
dedication that's serious dedication i'm
going to ask you questions a bit of a
flashback but um how was the transition
from going from regular degree life to
camera life before you started off
so what was that sorry so from from
normal life from a normal bow before you
started camera how was that transition
for you before i started only first no
before you you said oh sorry i've heard
cam girl yeah way before you yeah
yeah yeah how was that transition
i don't know i used to just literally i
didn't even take it as seriously as a
job like i would just pop on in an
evening and be like can i make a bit of
extra money i never thought i'd do it as
a job and i remember that first time
ever logging in
and i remember not even putting the
camera on my face i just had it on my
chest because i was like i can't look at
anyone i can't see anyone
and i was literally just sat on my sofa
and then when i started seeing the money
come in but when i first started you
could only because you have to get five
stars so you can charge more i was like
you started three stars so i could only
charge like three dollars a minute which
obviously then i lost 65 yeah so i used
to do like five nights a week and get
like 150 dollars
but i had no money back then okay so to
me
yeah okay and then when i could up my
price then it just got bigger and bigger
and then i got like regulars and fans so
before that i was just
literally just working in a call center
and
needed extra money because i couldn't
find my bills so i couldn't pay my car
and how was the transition from when you
started showing your face did you feel
like okay i need to stop my day-to-day
life and just focus on this yeah so my
my plan was to once i showed my face
that was it like not to do webcam
anymore because that was my whole
reasoning for like oh do you mean on cam
yeah oh right yeah
well i you can geographically hide
yourself from the uk so it was only ever
going to be other countries that could
see me oh okay so yeah so i just didn't
show my face because i was shy yeah yeah
yeah and then when i did only fans and
came on social media that's when i was
like
i used to really care what people
thought about me like i used to be
really like oh my god if someone finds
out i do webcoming and then when like
when your fans became more popular i was
like do you know what everyone else is
doing and where could i have been now if
i had just come out years ago so i just
like [ __ ] it basically decent okay
um how long were you doing it before i'm
assuming this is probably still in the
cam going how long were you doing it
before you could like quit your job and
stuff
uh what did you keep the course on the
job like yeah i kept my call center job
for a bit no yeah and then
i'd say about six months that's not long
that's not bad at all that's not long
that's not bad to start from fresh yeah
that's not bad at all well played though
yeah yeah that's decent yeah and then
you just become going and that's it
nothing else just come girl in yeah and
then um the reason i didn't do any fans
prior to that is because i didn't want
to put myself out there
like how else are you going to get of
course traction so yeah and then when i
decided to do that and i think it was
july last year that's when it all took
turn and now um i have an interesting
one so
obviously like only like you said like
only friends is like super popular now
um when it wouldn't have been before
what are your from your perspective from
the other side of it
like
we get loads of messages talking about
like the definition of like cheating
yeah so i'm a suit i'm just i already
know without even saying that i better
[ __ ] ton of the guys that are like
married with kids or whatever that
subscribe to you yeah
would you do you consider like
it a form of cheating at all if like
people subscribe to you or do you just
think it's like just like watching porn
that's a good question yeah
i it's a hard one because i feel like
for that person it's like more of an
escapism it's like fantasy you're never
gonna meet this person it's just like a
more interactive
porn as such yeah it's like but i feel
like yeah i feel like
if it was like emotional like
sorry
if it was more like emotional like you
were i mean some guys i do talk to but
like if it was more of like an emotional
heartfelt chat then i feel that was i
feel like that's a bit emotion i don't
know
i don't know i think it's like less
emotional only fans i think there's a
misconception like
you think that your boyfriend's gonna
meet this girl yeah like it's never
you're never gonna meet this person
but i get where like the woman's coming
from because i some i
probably would feel a bit betrayed i
think my thing is if they were like oh
i've not got any money to take you out
blah blah and then they're spending
money on only fans that's that's a
different argument yeah that's a
different idea that's where my head
would go that's a dick yeah yeah yeah
that's the wrong type of addiction yeah
i feel like that's where my head would
go if they were like we've got no money
can't go out can't do this and then i
found out you're on only fans yeah
interesting
it's funny about the um emotional thing
as well because i've spoken to so many
people in the past where they're like
they would be especially women they
would be more upset if they found out
that their guy like actually had like
not like a friend but like someone that
they had like an emotional connection
with rather than it was just a stranger
that they [ __ ]
if you know what i mean if they were on
the phone for three hours to some woman
every night
but they've never [ __ ] them or if it's
just a stranger that they [ __ ]
they're not out and never supposed to
again they'd be more upset
she'd be livid yeah bro three hours on a
couple of the next thing yeah yeah
she'll be living so do you think with
all the stuff that we spoke about do you
think it do you think if there's ever a
tippy point so obviously like you said
like you can just be like your everyday
subscriber
or you can like go the full shebang
would you put would you think like
would there ever be a point in what like
for example if one of your subscribers
was like
going for it going for it like
everything you had to offer they were
picking it up yeah would it get to a
point if you found out like they were
married you'd be thinking jesus christ
like you're married or would you think
still the same kind of it's just an
escape no yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't
bother well obviously it's not supposed
to yeah it's not to bother you but it's
not my business like i would never like
when they come on be like hi are you
married yeah yeah
i just wouldn't don't care
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
damn any more questions for you sir um
i was going to say
do you have another
juicy story you can share with us
just before we wrap up just before we
wrap up i have one more well i don't
know if it's juicy story i've a request
that i've had yeah i feel like it's a
really good one it's weird but it
reminds me of my childhood right okay so
it was on webcam okay and i would just
check this guy again he was just
chatting normal like just having chat
we're talking about like i'm born in the
90s he's born in the 90s he said oh do
you remember that show get your own back
you know where they'd slime the parents
yeah i do remember that
was it english was the english show yeah
like it was um it's on like bbc three or
two or something like that yeah it was
called getting back where you likely
your who are the [ __ ] guys that used
to run that show what were they called
brav
was it dick and dom that did that
something i don't even know this i don't
remember you've never seen i don't
remember too fair you were deprived as a
kid you never he's never been to toys r
us
[Laughter]
yeah
that is sad yeah sorry yeah get your own
back yeah well they basically they'd put
their parents on like
a mechanical thing they'd be like a
little mechanical seat and they'd ask
them questions and then they'd get like
close they're ever closer to okay okay
at the end like the kids getting their
own back on their parents and they do
that and they dunk him in the slack so i
thought oh my god yeah i love that show
and he was like how much for you to dunk
yourself in slime
did you answer
i said i don't have any slime and he
said you have anything in your kitchen
like slime like beans and i was like
i'm not pouring cold beans on myself
i'm not putting cold beans on my face oh
it depends on how much he says well yeah
the site was getting 65
yeah
literally every decision i ever made
very very true so yeah i didn't really
do much fetish stuff on there to be fair
just the um
like the emoji
that's a big fetish is it really
yeah
why
i don't know well i don't know it's just
at least once a day i'll get asked for
that
like just like a [ __ ] rate or what yeah
they'll just please humiliate my small
penis
how do you do that with a straight face
like how do you go about your day
texting what do you know they sometimes
want you to laugh like laughing oh yeah
i can imagine yeah you wouldn't need to
do it with a stranger sometimes they're
like can you ring me with your friends
and show them my dick pic and all just
laugh
have you done that no i've not done that
so i don't get friends involved
[ __ ] fair
that is insane but i mean if they
offered my money i'm sure my friends
would
get involved jesus christ yeah so yeah
they'll just be like can you just
laugh at me laugh at me make me feel
like [ __ ] yeah
they're so fascinating that is very very
not even like in a funny way like that's
fascinating
they're probably just like
seriously like big boys
at work
they're probably the boss's boss's boss
at work yeah yeah they're tired of
telling people what to do
they just want to be bullied yeah that's
the only way they can get they can get
there yeah yeah that's incredible but
yeah man
thank you so much for coming on youtube
um
first guest in this studio first of many
yep um and we'll throw all of your your
links and stuff like that hopefully this
one will go viral and then you'll just
get like a million hundreds of thousands
of assistant or something to deal with
the 16 hours a day because our stuff is
just too much it's too much um but yeah
man guys comment let us know what you
think about this one yeah um and then
yeah we'll do it again
love love thank you thank you so much
guys
time to take a very quick break from the
episode to spread some love
on our boys and girls over at man
scoop you know the vibes um so guys
father's day is just around the corner
close
very very close coming and our friends
at mindscape are here to ensure all the
father figures out there
are looking
daddy material this oh
daddy material this tune oh yes okay
so manscape performance package 4.0
which includes the signature lawnmower
4.0 is the toots
uh it's the perfect bundle to tackle any
and all old man hair from head to toe
everywhere bro this right here is no dad
joke
hey this right here is no dad joke hey
are you
treat him and yourself and join the four
million men worldwide who trust manskate
with this exclusive offer guys okay so
if you want to get 20 off and free
shipping worldwide go to manscape.com
manskip.com and use the code sng sierra
november golf sng manscape.com and trust
me his dad bod will thank you
all right guys thank you very much let's
get back to the episode okay guys
welcome back beau has been and gone hope
you enjoyed the juicy only fans talks
yeah man um
all our deets are in the description
below they probably popped up on the
screen as well yeah subscribe to us make
sure you subscribe subscribe to that and
let us know what you say
subscribe and run the feedback yeah
basically yeah yeah
subscribe and run your feed subscribe to
the channel what did she say it was
seven dollars seven dollars yeah
subscribe to the thing let us know what
it's saying just so we just so we know
just so we're aware yeah because we see
her in we've seen her in the public like
we don't really know what's going on
over there behind the scenes yeah she
didn't go into details
um so yeah obviously
if you can afford it run at the coffee
money right yeah true one of the
requestings um because yeah she said
she's not she hadn't done a kink at king
ting in a minute in a minute so yeah the
money's never been right
maybe you could be one of them or the
girl now
if you want to you think you've got deep
pockets and run it up but let's see
let's see man yeah give us the feedback
so yeah it'll be it'll be hella
interested yeah man juicy right let's
get down to it bro hit me guys so
obviously every week you know the vibes
ig question
haha
last week i asked you man pet hates
about your partner slash significant
other and as per guys
do you see responses yeah so i hate each
other fam i said to you before these men
don't want to be in relationships
a lot of these men don't want to be in
relationships they're just there because
they've been together for so long it's
and they just [ __ ] hate you they just
[ __ ] hate each other i'm ready
all right let's go let's go let's go
let's go let's go i'm ready i'm ready
i'm ready
this is the first one i wrote and it
reminded me of you of me
okay go on go on
leaving empty cans in the car
bro facts
fact the thing is as well
in my defense yeah
bro i just
i uh i only change it when i need the
slot available yeah yeah when i need the
copper available that's when i'm
changing it yeah because fam sometimes
and don't get me wrong i want a clean
car yeah i want to lit up yes
i don't want to wait for a bin i want to
lit up i want to dash the camera said i
want to literally bro that's hilarious
when i'm driving yeah it's only i only
figure out these i never figure out
these things because how do i explain it
once i get home i'm home yeah i'm not
cleaning out cars i want to close the
door and get upstairs and take my
[ __ ] shoes
change out of these jeans
get comfy cup
that's what i want to do i want to put
on some netflix yeah i'm not thinking
about cleaning out cars yeah as soon as
i'm home i'm home i'm not thinking about
nothing yeah and i'm a last minute nelly
okay when i'm leaving the yard i ain't
cleaning up cars i'm in a rush yeah
where i always leave at the last [ __ ]
minute so i'm not cleaning anything now
yeah so it's only once i'm mid drive and
i'm eased into it then i'll look down
and see empty cans and i want to dash it
yeah but i'm not going to do it so it's
always wait and wait away and it's only
when i pull up to a shop and think oh
let me get myself a cheeky monster
realize there's two camps up there then
i'll dash them in a bit fair enough are
you one of them ones where as well when
you get your car washed you do the
inside as well
uh it depends
it um
sometimes i'm thinking about getting
into the whole
at home violating okay valet valid
uh because their services they'll cut i
think it's like 60 70 quid they come to
you and they'll come to your yards dude
outside to the inside you didn't have to
be there and then you just pay them and
and that's it i think i might do that
because um
well maybe you even pay online that
would be even better that would be
better yeah so i'm pretty sure you would
pay yeah i'm pretty sure you probably
pay on the spot yeah so yeah i think i'd
rather do that because i don't ever end
up um having them clean inside because i
don't want to get out of the car
away
it's usually it's [ __ ] england so
it's usually raining or cold or some
[ __ ] and it's just nice i usually a lot
of time i go in there with the intention
of thinking you know what i'm going to
let them clean the inside and then i get
there and they're like
and i'm like nasty outside i got [ __ ]
time for this too no
just too outside all right
you're not coming in i'm not coming out
all right reminder guys just pet hey
it's about your partner significant
other
when he says take my big dick but he's
only packing two inches oh wow
this is
this is what concerns me like yeah
this is it's because it's twofold yeah
does he actually think he has a big dick
or what's human soul
if two inches is [ __ ] small yeah but
how many obviously yes you seen porn but
okay i'll let you finish and ask a
question all right so what i was gonna
say is does he think it's a big dick
or
does he think
you're my woman
uplift me yeah so if i tell you to take
this fat dick yeah tell me how big it is
because this is what i want if i've got
no one else to do this with yeah like i
want to feel good about it but how would
you feel knowing that you know it's a
two inch and she knows it's a two inches
so she knows she's lying to you
lie to me
it'll make you feel good in the in the
moment yeah while i'm banging because i
doubt he says it just in the kitchen
he says it when they want to buffer she
[ __ ] laugh at him man people say the
most
in the moment i've said some
whose dick is this
i've actually never said that
i've never said that
no
i've never said it they'll say it to me
okay okay wanting me to be like yours
yes
whose dick is when they're on whose dick
is this
[ __ ] please
is that a nip
that's my diary
that's my phone book
and let me find out yeah check
what date is it
what's the date
if it's tuesday it might be charlotte's
yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] you know
that's hilarious oh bro i thought man
did this for the
nipples
sharp
that's hilarious yeah bro yeah this
whole people that's the thing i people
chat [ __ ] yeah in the act yeah right if
man's saying he might be to be thinking
bro we all know i ain't got a big dick
yeah but i'm trying to [ __ ] have fun
yeah yeah she's delighted me [ __ ]
nice to me
oh my god that's jokes
she does
sock shoe sock shoe instead of sock sock
shoe shoe she has
one sock and shoe on before she has a
second sock on yeah
i can never see that that'll be a pet
peeve of mine as well i wouldn't i could
never see we would have to adjust i'll
start throwing [ __ ] we'd have to address
it yeah because i read that and had to
read it again because i wasn't sure what
he meant that would [ __ ] piss me off
sock shoe socks there's just a bare foot
here and then sock and then shoe again
it makes no sense
[ __ ] where's your symmetry yeah yeah
we couldn't watch a single show slash
movie without her trying to mount me
oh but i'll say that that would
frustrate me it would piss me off i'm a
lover of tv yeah
i'm a lover let me watch my show yeah
yeah she thinks netflix is for this no
yeah yeah no i'm actually trying to
digest this information yeah that would
over a certain period of time i'd like
it if we've just met rags and this is
the first week we're getting in to know
each other the first few weeks yeah do
that rags yeah but after that once we
actually enjoy each other's
when you're here often and i'm there
often you're always trying to oh let's
watch simon babe
and you're like yeah and then 10-20
minutes in shut big man yeah get the
[ __ ] off me get the [ __ ] off me and also
pause it
suck do you know rude when they just let
it play and then they just want to [ __ ]
pause this because i'm i'm not going to
be expected to remember to rewind it
because that's actually embarrassing
after you've banged and you haven't
really yet you're just sat there naked
just rewinding the thing and you're just
like where where where where where where
where where are we babe did we see this
bit
pause it pause it [ __ ] me and then just
watch it again pause it because i'm
going to get distracted oh yeah rags i'm
going to hear something juicy while i'm
banging my eyes are going to gaze
pause it
[ __ ] pause it
rags
one chick just put his height
of course she did of literal course she
did he can't tie his laces so he wears
those jordans with the velcro strap roll
crosstalk oh no
what do you mean he can't do it
what does that actually mean fam
i don't he must
he must like do it up and then tuck the
laces in or something like squeeze it so
it's tight and then
probably
[ __ ] hell oh god
her friends scream when they see her
that was jarmy oh that's such a yeah i
think it is a yeah that'll piss me off
pigeon neck when he drives fast
what's that fam i've been trying to
visualize as i wrote it down i think
it's like this yeah yeah yeah he thinks
he's like this hitch
hitch up yeah yeah wearing a football
jersey around the house or outside and
his team isn't even playing
fair
you do that to be fair
yeah you can wear it yeah you just wear
it because you wear it yeah let him wear
it now it pisses her off
in certain angles he looks kind of ugly
[ __ ] me yeah they don't want to be
together she
it's actually dread when it gets to a
point where couples are looking at each
other thinking you're actually not even
attractive bro
what are we doing here bro what the [ __ ]
are we actually doing here tough tough
she tried to facetime me when there's
football on tv that would yeah
back to back when he screams at the tv
watching football ick
[Laughter]
she picks off her scabs and eats them
she's no she's 23.
that's not a peeve bro that's
that's we have to end this asylum you're
eating scabs yes i had a messiah
one chick put his wife
[Laughter]
she knows she's number two bro
she's been number two she's trying
to watch she's trying to level up when
are you going to leave her said his eyes
eye roll she put the eye roll
emoji she's vex but she wants the dick
she can't go anywhere when are you going
to leave it you've told me time and time
again you're going to leave her when
she's not just like shut up shut up
shut up you're so boring with
i'll leave when i leave when i'm ready
yeah yeah change your locks
if you don't want me to change the locks
if you do sharp
shut up and gobble that yeah
he leaves cupboards opens and never puts
the lids back on drinks oh that would
piss me off
the cupboard things too much champ about
seven or eight i was scrolling through
about seven eight to ten people put this
cupboard thing and it really baffled me
why would you not close the cupboard i
could i can't imagine opening i'm not
closing it it just doesn't yeah same
that's exactly the same thing when i
thought the other day when i thought you
didn't turn the light switch back off
when you when it wasn't working or
whatever yeah but
to me that was exactly like one of those
rattles oh 100 i was riding 100 i was
rattled give them context bro okay cool
so guys for context
uh we went out in london the other week
and four got an airbnb so um i went to
visit him there and i i bought some food
to eat so i went to the kitchen and i
went to turn the light on and it was one
of them old-school [ __ ] lights that
massive one through the middle yeah the
long thin rectangle one through the
middle um and it uses those eco bulbs
yeah so you turn it on and the [ __ ]
doesn't react straight like 15-20
seconds so i thought it was broken so i
was on there and did turn on it's not
working turn off
i said to fuhad
uh no i didn't even say anything he
clocked and was like oh no no i said the
light doesn't work and he said no it
does you just have to leave it
for um like 10-15 seconds and it will
turn on so i said oh and then i turned
it back on and i said hang on
how do you know that and he's like what
and i was like brav are you about to
tell me
that you walked in here
turned the light on
for oh [ __ ] it doesn't work and then
just walked off
and then by accident you discovered oh
it does work it's on now and you didn't
switch it back off
i was thinking now you're a [ __ ]
psycho luckily he justified himself
luckily just oh this actually brings me
[Music]
this actually means i get to announce it
okay
to be fair i think we spoke about this
on patreon we did speak about this on
patreon okay so it's only going to be uh
in context of for the patrons but i'll
try and give uh i'll try and give
context for you guys right so
check this out guys i had
a
certified victory over who had the other
day a certified victory i'm still not
even sure if i got my apology but if i
haven't i'm gonna get it now so
[Laughter]
a few weeks ago on patreon i said tofu i
explained to you ad about one of my pet
peeves of him
is that he doesn't bring his wallet
anywhere and we had a situation
uh like a year ago where me and him went
out for breakfast or or lunch their card
machine wasn't working so we had to pay
in cash food didn't have his wallet
which means he didn't have a card to get
cash out from the atm so then i had to
get the cash out pay for it etc etc so i
made this whole song and dance and asked
him do you now bring out your wallet he
told me with his chest that he still
doesn't bring out his wallet
i said cool if we get into one of these
situations again i'm never going to
forgive you just know that
just know that i can't forgive you after
this conversation i can't forgive you if
you if you're allowing if you're not
going to be willing to change your
behavior
after this conversation we can't be boys
yeah and he said cool say less daddy
on
the weekend
we go to harry potter's birthday party
we get we wait in the queue for an hour
we get to the front of the queue
and the lady says
ids please
i grabbed him by the soda he grabbed the
back of my shoulder i said you're going
to hate me put his chin to my earlobe
and said bro you're going to hate me
you knew it you didn't wanted to elbow
you in the nose
i couldn't believe the [ __ ] betrayal
the cheek and the betrayal after that
conversation that we had that you still
didn't bring your wife you know what was
funny do you know what was funny whilst
we're in the queue i had a thought like
[ __ ] maybe they might ask for id's
obviously no and i've not even brought
my wallet so i checked and looked at the
um invite did you say bring an idea it
said it didn't say anything so i it took
like a oh thank god like to myself but
that's mad that you actually think like
not actually not that you actually think
but that like
to me
anywhere that has a bouncer located i'm
going to need my id yeah
anywhere for some reason i don't know
like
i don't i just don't know why i didn't
bring it because i didn't even bring it
to london yeah oh i know you said it's
in manchester you said manny
just go back to the bnb and get it it
was on my desk bro
oh i was so angry luck and i was even
more angry because luckily we managed to
get in yeah and no one asked for the
idea and you were like carl yeah and you
were just like calm have you got your
wallet now
no
oh yes i do i do i do i do because i
have to go for the barbers i need to get
my um i'll get a trim yeah all right so
let's get money out
but yeah anyway so that's a dub for me
yeah so that's proven that's proven that
i won't yeah all right
see say sorry i'm not bad no don't say
my bad my bad say sorry man my bad no
say sorry sorry in it safety same it's
all right
it's all right for now for now yeah but
if it's only all right because we got in
because if we didn't get in yeah you
would have a few minutes oh
i would have been fuming until now i
know we wouldn't we wouldn't we probably
wouldn't have spoke up until when we put
the camera on and i pretend like
everyone's alright and then as soon as
the episode's done i will turn the
camera off and i'll just walk out
i probably just woke up oh god that's
hilarious oh
jesus i know you know how angry i was
but i don't think you do
i was [ __ ] you think it's so angry i
knew fanbase the reason why i grabbed
your shoulder and said you're gonna
[ __ ] hate me so i couldn't be asked
for you to make a scene i just i just
needed to tell the information sharp
just know i haven't got my wedding
[ __ ] sharp
because i was gonna pat in a way for us
to get in how i don't know and i don't
care it doesn't matter anymore we nearly
even didn't get in anyway it doesn't
matter anymore it doesn't matter anymore
it doesn't matter all right i'm gonna
let it slide because it doesn't matter
i'm gonna let it slide
for future references
for certain occasions i will bring my
wallet not in every occasion
but i will bring my wallet when bounces
are involved going forward i will bring
my wallet that should be a known
negotiable anyway that's nothing to do
with me i know
i don't know
that should be a standard i just wasn't
thinking i wasn't thinking and that's
just like being less
all right moving on
all right quick reminder pet hates blah
blah blah
he gets really offended by my farts
we've been together for three years for
goodness sake
i told you i keep it sexy
i keep it sexy all the time yeah we all
do i'm not fighting in front of anyone
well to be fair i've never had i said
never i've not had a long ass term
relationship that i feel like i'm in a
position to be comfortable to start
fighting yeah well i've only been in one
relationship where she was like
she was the
same as this lady in terms of she got
angry at me for hating the fact that she
would fart like near me and she was the
protagonist yeah yeah and then she would
just be like bro like it's [ __ ]
natural like deal with it and i'm like i
am dealing with it but it's just not
sexy bro yeah yeah if you want us to be
bedrooms we can be bedriddens
that's it help me yeah if you want us to
be boys we can be boys but if you want
to [ __ ] don't fart near me i i don't
know why
i don't know why this is a decision i
don't know why this is hard to
comprehend it's not sexy
and that's just that yeah and if you're
fine with that then i'm fine with it
yeah right that's hilarious
his speech impediment oh that's not fair
you know that when you met him family
are you stuck there you stuck with him
yeah yeah that's not [ __ ] fair he's
suddenly he suddenly forgets how to open
a bottle of bleach after redecorating
the toilet
bro to be fair
i can't imagine sometimes being a woman
and living with like a [ __ ] grim
animal yeah
what is that you look at the toilet it's
just [ __ ] caked
[ __ ] like a public toilet and he just
shot on there washed his hands on the
left dipped and he didn't think about it
again and she has to sit there like for
[ __ ] sake and actually clean his [ __ ]
and you live with that you live without
a sit down yeah i have to have a sit
down [ __ ] dealing with it
i'm not [ __ ] deal with it i wouldn't
because i didn't even deal with one of
you man
we could be housemates
like that rags we're gonna have to arm
wrestle or fight or satin to get it off
because it needs to be squashed
i'm wrestling yeah like it's one thing
if you're going to keep doing it yeah i
need some kind of satisfaction
it needs to be a yank to your ears yeah
yeah yeah because if we're going to rock
in there like bro you keep [ __ ] doing
this if you turn around abroad do not be
rude this is my yard as well if i'm i'm
gonna [ __ ] i'm gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] all
right cool because that's how we're
gonna do because i don't wanna look for
a new housemate i don't wanna fall out
let's [ __ ] fight for the next six
minutes
for the next six minutes on guard
let's [ __ ] fight and it doesn't i
want to get it all out here
so even if i lose it's off my chest
that's hilarious oh [ __ ] it out
leaving one square of toilet paper on
the roll so he doesn't have to change it
oh that would [ __ ] piss me off as
well
humor that resonates that would [ __ ]
piss me off that and not even
the worst one of that is just not even
changing it yeah just finishing the
whole team and she's leaving leaving the
thing there leaving the
brown tape
the brown [ __ ] cardboard on the tin
oh my goodness eats ice cream with gravy
no you don't apparently he does that's
[ __ ] disgusting he sucks his fingers
after he's eaten it gives me the ick we
get married today pray for me
wow
he lies for no reason i could ask him if
he's had lunch today and he's saying no
because he thinks something else
man's always on edge he's a such a chief
he's such a she eaten today no baby no
why i just haven't
he's he's ready for the follow-up he's
thinking
well i did but
while i was there this
it's not working up
let me just say no
she's gonna ask for the receipts it's
just not gonna make sense i ordered yeah
i would have started to share
and she's going to think it's us
start because it comes up to shatter on
everything
she's not going to have it
i think it sucks that's hilarious
his feet go outwards when he walks
penguins like a penguin
he's got a better ass and lashes than me
that's your business that is her
business
he sounds like a buff guy
lash isn't a perky bag
it's a man
the one nut and done him ko'd whilst i
rub one out quietly next to him
regretting being in love
wow
scent for man wow
this is the thing i think i think we
spoke about this bad times already but
um
like
for me
just
because i think we spoke about it so
a lot of time obviously we record an
episode it goes out everyone la dee da
da but then obviously new people when
they come on they'll go through older
episodes yes
and i think we spoke a while ago i don't
know when it was we spoke about like why
girls even bother faking orgasms because
at the end of the day they kind of need
to be we kind of need to know
do you know what i mean yeah we need to
know like if you're unhappy tell me
you're unhappy
true true true
and yeah i don't understand like at this
big i guess
we're older than some people but like
i really really wish women were just
more vocal because
when the man's not around
they're all chat chat chat on [ __ ]
youtube podcasts whatever group chats
whenever they're more than one females
they love to run joke about how man
can't make them nut but when they're in
that act they want to keep their mouth
shut true a lot of times they don't want
to say [ __ ] i mean
i think that's twofold one they don't
want to ruin the moment because they're
as even if they're not i'm assuming
they're still in having a good time
yeah of course and two i feel like they
may feel like this is just my assumption
they may feel like if they bring up in
the act as opposed to post act or even
at all
they would feel like they're escalating
him yeah i get that um the thing is with
me is like not even to be fair like
a lot of that i think is all well and
good when like you're casually [ __ ]
someone or if the first time you're
[ __ ] someone or whatever but like if
you're in like a long-term relationship
thing
like tell me like big man
i need to not so before you [ __ ] me you
best eat me out i'm trying to come in
your mouth before you fight me and then
i'm good just just tell me fair fair
it's a long term thing we're going to be
here for a while and you're out here
rubbing things out when i'm asleep
regrettably being in love oh
that's tough man that is tough anyway
moving on my ex called me dad during sex
not daddy
dad
wow wow
he told me to wax my back i did and he
didn't even notice
[Laughter]
i would be livid this next one sweetened
me go on he goes on his tiptoes to get
plates from the cupboard oh
that's not his fault though
that's actually not his fault he needs
that thug ladder
bro
[ __ ] hell yes just dread
i don't think he washes his foreskin
properly now i can't give him the head
that i want
yuck
when he broke his ankle and had to wear
a boot for four weeks gave me the ick
women are just savage bro
we're only humans
we're literally only humans being savage
yeah yeah picking up things with his
toes like a monkey
i feel like we've had that bad times
this is just turned into ix now isn't it
yeah this is just slightly transitioned
into things
it looks like he struggles when he tries
to open soda
the gun yeah
[Laughter]
she looks like in a peripheral [ __ ]
now he's struggling yeah just open the
can bro [ __ ] you now he cries every time
he has a drink
oh alcohol
oh that that's that's a massive pet
peeve
that's a huge one
makes me lap up his bum hole once he
nuts he plays them like he didn't like
it pnc at his finest
[Laughter]
that would be me down to a t that'll be
me down to a t once you not fam [ __ ]
tell anyone
sometimes i hate
being reminded of [ __ ]
not like even talking sexually yeah yeah
some things like you just don't want to
be reminded of like oh you love disney
movie isn't it just sharp and let me
enjoy it in peace let me live my life
yeah yeah yeah
so if i was
if i was getting my [ __ ] eight to
pieces
and then after she was like you love
when i eat that isn't it
shut your mouth shut the [ __ ] up don't
ever say that again no i [ __ ] don't
you love it so i let you do it
you'll be on the defense roll
you love when i eat that ass in it
no i don't why are you saying that i
don't think you understand no one can
tell me i feel so small
i'd feel so small why are you saying
that it's not it's just not sexy
literally no i don't
i'll be bright red bro no i [ __ ]
don't
wow i love whatever you
oh that's so funny his lisp i watch i
would catch myself mimicking him for fun
it was awful
that's peak that is peak you just hate
him just leave me alone
when they open the door just to stare at
me and then walk out
i have to come out the house to help
i'll help her parallel park embarrassing
oh that would charm me bro i remember
when i was younger you've been obviously
you've been on my uh where my mom lives
yes the street of course [ __ ] steep
of course thin yeah and steep yeah yeah
bro every time i had like a girl come to
visit me in the whole like ten years i
lived there or whatever
the first time they would come they
would all either park three streets away
and be like i don't know where your yard
is come and find me
or they'll bail me and be like i'm
outside i can't park and i have to go
out there and park a car
bear times
bare times bro
when he tries to tell the kids off and
addresses them as guys like the wetland
as he is
that took a turn in it
like the wet lettuce he is because he
calls his kids guys guys come on come on
guys come on guys i've asked you twice
i've asked you three times now your
mom's getting angry guys come on just
come on you're taking the taking the
biscuit
like the wet lettuce he is punish them
be a man [ __ ] punish
wow
i found out after two months of talking
that he was a suffering tick tock rapper
bro i was talking to one of our boys
about this the other day
i don't know how
musician musicians yeah quote unquote
yeah these days
stomach trying to come up through
tick-tock because there's not really any
other way yeah to do things yeah when
i'm just scrolling luckily my algorithm
doesn't send it to me too much but when
i'm scrolling i'm just saying duets
duets and covers yeah i'm thinking stop
yeah stop stop a struggling tick-tock
rapper who had yeah that's um
it's detrimental
my this this one triggered me my ex used
to spell definitely as defiantly
the amount of times i've seen someone
type definitely as the finale
yeah it's disturbing it's [ __ ]
annoying it's disturbing yeah bro it's
bear annoying
he'd have nightmares and smack me in his
sleeves
oh that's funny
ah
he walked into a glass door and i
couldn't see him the same way again
fam that happened in morocco oh it
didn't happen to me it happened to a
chick right
um it was i don't know i don't know if
you remember but massive pandora's i
think massive pan sliding was massive
and this chick was trying to like peep
outside she got so close and banged her
head on the table
i laughed my ass off i bet you [ __ ]
it happened to me the next day no it
didn't
i was looking through banged my head
i was like oh carmen she available
instantly did she see she was she
available
she saw it she saw it but i honed up to
it straight away
laugh if you want to laugh yeah bro if
if if that happened to me and then the
next day it happened to you i wouldn't
ever let it drop i'll be lobbing eggs at
you i'll be calling everyone and just
fake laughing just pointing at you
belittling you
he fills the hands up with water when
it's empty [ __ ] you i lie literally [ __ ]
you if i'm
if i if i squat water into my hand
nutty looking water
because it's it's what's the viscosity
is very thin
straight in your face
[ __ ] pissed off
he would get more excited to see my best
friend than me
she put in brackets
she is his type as well
dread
it's so funny
i've often thought that about my dad you
know
talk to me yeah
my dad is a really i think my dad loves
hosting he's kind of like a quiet person
okay he's a great host and he makes
people feel [ __ ] comfortable okay so
whenever i've brought like girls to him
or whatever he makes them feel literally
you're in the family from now
so my dad is very much like that so like
whenever
um his like wife's sister comes or like
in the past where he's had like his
girlfriend's friends come or anyone he
makes them feel comfortable bro so he
will just chat to them for time yeah and
i often think they have to think i
wonder if it just pisses her off yeah
you treat them so much better than you
treat me yes you treat them so nice when
they're up in this [ __ ] house like
what is wrong with you he's a child yeah
you barely say two words to me he's a
charmer yeah yeah that's jokes
she's serious about star signs
i promise you now i can never do a thing
with a girl who's genuinely adamant
about star science yeah that's a lot
we'd have to be a pinch of salt like you
have to deep down no it's not real
do i mean
like we can do this song and dance as
much as you want to do it whatever makes
you happy but i need to know that you
know it's not real
we would have found out before we got to
that stage yeah you can't be living with
me and you think star signs are like
affecting your life yeah well you'll
know like literally day one as soon as
they ask you what your star sign is and
then if it's face to face anyway yeah
and you see the genuine reaction yeah i
don't know if they're like aquarius
oh really that's so funny because they
don't
or if they were like no you're not yeah
red flag red [ __ ] flag
my ex lives abroad
oh sorry my ex that lives abroad left
the valentine's card i sent him unopened
on my doorstep last week
that's not even a pet peeve that's just
a confession
wow so hang on
she sent
so she sent them a valentine's day card
while they were together i'm assuming
they broke up he never opened it they
broke up
and then when he came back to the uk or
wherever they are he just wanted to let
her know just so you know i never
[ __ ] opened this stupid piece also
just just so you know i'm back and
you're not on it i'm ju you're just not
for me
he left he didn't even post he left it
on the doorstep that's how he that's how
he wanted to make her know it wasn't the
postman it wasn't like a return to
sender
[ __ ] i'm back
never opened it here's your card
wow he's bitter that is very bitter he's
bitter i'll just not open it or just
left it or whatever yeah i would have
better that's a lot more mental effort
but as i'm saying like i don't give a
[ __ ] enough about anything yeah to drive
to someone's house to let them know
in the hope the wind doesn't [ __ ]
take it
show me in the hope that she's not in
yeah family imagine putting it down she
opens the door
because have you ever seen like a ring
doorbell of course and you can hear
sometimes you can hear motion detected
at the front door
i do it to my car
she will see it on her phone why does
that work that's embarrassing yeah he'd
be on twitter that day
he needs a silicon wait he needs a
silicone ring around his dick to stay
hard now
i'll just squeeze the blood in there
oh wow
[Music]
that's her pet peeve
and that sounds like a medical condition
i don't know like yes that's harsh
that's like me saying like ah we have to
use lube every time true because it just
can't get wet [ __ ] pet peeve
all right lever in it
she has the breath
of a thousand foreskins
yo
why is someone in that relationship
wow
how does he know what foreskin smells
like like that
just the breath of a thousand foreskins
jesus too funny to call bread
he acted like he was a six foot five
model but he was five nine and a [ __ ]
shag
[ __ ]
he colors in his receding hairline and
it's not even straight
that's dread that's [ __ ] dread he's
so insecure about it as well
oh it's not even straight wow
she doesn't know the difference between
brought and bought
i think a lot of people don't that's a
pet peeve of mine that's i've that's
i've never seen that happen before what
brought them bought i've never seen
anyone be confused about that really
it's usually what i find is when people
they use it like oh i brought you this
from the shop which is technically true
but that's not yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
fair enough yeah i went to the shop i
brought you this
[Music]
i'd surprise my ex in lingerie
he'd walk straight past me and go to bed
really really
this when i say some of these men or
women don't want to be in relationships
brother
i'd surprise him in lingerie and he'd
walk straight past and go to sleep that
if i'm the chick that would rock my
confidence she's never doing anything
sexual towards him ever again ever again
he's missed out
what did
he acknowledge this did he say anything
she went to bed bro oh [ __ ]
me fighting on my dog's nose she sneezed
and fainted
the dog
what's this god do it i don't know i've
read it and laughed i had to put it in
there i had to put it in there this
chick put this [ __ ] got me pregnant
that's [ __ ] funny
i've got t-more
the fact that her brother's a pro-boxer
i want to end things with her but i'm
afraid he'll kill me
fam
i remember
when i was younger and i broke up with
this one girl yeah
and then all of a sudden this is so just
i broke up with this girl yeah she
threatened me with a cousin i'd never
heard of we've been together for like
two and a half years no she threatened
me with a cousin i've never heard of and
i was like saying what who's like
you're lucky i've had to talk down my
cousin from coming to knock you out and
i was like
whoo
she was like oh my cousin from london
this is that right
i think this was overtaken i ello well
i was like big man
shut up
next day i had a friend request for some
random dude
and he messaged me
like
he just chatting the most about your
luck i don't come down here [ __ ] kill
you the way you treat my cousin like
this i was like big man
who
are you is this an alias yeah
you've never been mentioned before this
is so weird bro
i was a little bit scared
i was a little bit because it was coming
from he was actually sending me on
facebook
and so i know it's unhinged yeah
because what kind of sociopath actually
considers himself to be that guy yeah
because at this day and age like imagine
you had like a female cousin yeah that
you're clearly not close enough that
they don't even mention you exist
very true but then they break up their
boyfriend and they hit you up like oh my
boyfriend just broke my heart
can you just like scare me move him up
i knew you'd be like yeah yeah you think
you're bad enough like yeah yeah yeah
say let's say let's say let's see what's
his name yeah
i'll message him now
after two in a bit years no and you've
never been mentioned it's obviously an
alias
i told it after i think i think after
like two days of harassment
i thought it was fam i said ask her for
my address and rock up when you rock it
yeah this is boring i'm not doing this
yeah this is all long asking for the
address
after two days of constant harassment
and it wasn't even finding anymore i was
like
tell her to give you the address rock up
whenever you're wrong
let's have it out yeah i'm tired yeah
fam
just make sure sociable hours
i go to bed at this time
if it's after 10 i promise you i'm not
coming outside
[Laughter]
oh it's hilarious last but not least he
can't swim
on holiday he had to wear a life jacket
when we went into the ocean oh god
that is embarrassing so embarrassing
i can imagine
the ick she got oh one million percent
[ __ ] one million percent just did you
see the video of hedy one trying to swim
on
the other day i did brother
i've never seen so many splashes
that's survival he knew he could stand
up but he was struggling to survive
bro not being able to swim is is
seriously serious it's serious
i just it just doesn't everyone's
swapping primary school no no apparently
no apparently not and this is the thing
this is what doesn't actually make sense
to me we need to address it now why
can't black people swim i don't know
because i can swim oh i know you can
i've seen you do it i can swim brother
can toby swim
i don't know um i want to say yes i want
to say it's cause i think he can
we had a we had a pool because we
obviously went obviously but we went to
the same secondary school um and we had
a pool and i'm pretty sure
we had like swimming lessons and stuff
so i'm pretty sure you can see him but
i'm not seeing him swimming here so i
don't know i don't remember what he's
doing in his swim
um
i think he can because when we're all in
the pool in miami there's only jay that
can swim i'm sorry i'm sure of it oh
yeah i forgot about that i forgot about
miami yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah um and ty
because i beefer as well i'm sure we
went in the pool i totally didn't come
to my before
oh yes he did oh yes he did what am i
talking about i'm thinking of marbella
all right yeah yeah when did he go in
the pool and
um
we did go into nepal in ibiza because it
was warm as [ __ ] i remember that i was
warm and i felt it it was gross
i remember now it just came back to me
um but yeah bro most black people like
me can't swim that's nuts it's wild my
dad told me to swim from early from when
i was a uu i was swimming in primary
school yeah and once you can do it it's
done it's done it's like riding a bike
yeah literally once you can do it it's
done you don't even need to be good yeah
just learn basics yeah i remember my
stepdad i couldn't swim one time i think
i might have told his story my stepdad
when i was growing up couldn't swim and
he had too much of an eco okay because i
didn't i when i was this young i didn't
understand that humans couldn't swim
yeah like adults yeah if you're an adult
you can swim yeah you thought
so i remember we went on holiday to
france and they we were in this pool and
had a wave machine
okay and i used to tell him uh he used
to take me to the deep end and dash me
in yeah dash me in and i said step back
my step down okay my pops could swim
okay my stepdad who was black
would dash me in and i was like ah yeah
this is sick and um i must have been i
was young i think i was probably like
eight uh maybe like
10 tops let's say that
so yeah that's like jump in jump in
the water's great jump in and i was like
no no no no no
and i was like oh my man yeah yeah yeah
and he was like no no no no like i think
i can't remember if he said i can't swim
or not but he was just like nah nah nah
and i was like what are you talking
about bro i'm like come on jump in
let's like let's ramp in the water
whatever and he was like oh all right
jumped in
flapping around that
help it's
help no he never who has he never as a
child
seeing
a quote unquote male role model in my
life
ick
to this day i remember it i was
disgusted help
help
and my mom was like oh [ __ ]
he was flapping in there no i can't swim
somebody [ __ ] help oh and luckily the
waves drifted him onto the wall yeah he
grabbed the wall and he struggled to get
out and i remember as he got out his
back crack was showing because of the
what drapes the change the shots down oh
i remember thinking yuck you're not a
man oh
he wanted to bury himself that day yeah
he wanted to bury it i remember thinking
two things
one
why did you jump in he wanted to impress
you yeah i'm not impressed with you but
like i'm exactly that's what you're
eager
i'm not a yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm not
painting that's drawing you up like i'm
a [ __ ] kid yeah you don't need to
impress me big one you can't swim so
what did you think how did you think
this was gonna go
oh [ __ ] you know that's hilarious and
here yeah and and two i just think you'd
do you're a joke brother
i just remember thinking yuck that is
very icky you can't be my role model you
just can't you can't you literally can't
and i'm yeah i'm thinking who can't swim
and then i remember yeah when i was at
uh working at david lloyd
every single time
an african family would sign up
the first thing that they would say do
you do swimming lessons for adults
really every single time wow every
single time i signed up i wonder what
the family common denominator is like i
don't know not the fact that they're
african or black or whatever but i
wonder why there's a correlation between
black people and not being able to swim
it really doesn't make sense they just
don't learn and it doesn't make sense
whether because it also doesn't make
sense that it doesn't matter where they
were raised
england caribbean [ __ ] africa none of
them learned to swim it doesn't make any
[ __ ] sense yeah yeah i don't know i i
yeah i didn't learn but i learned before
i went to primary school but i we did we
did it in primary school as well i
learned it i think yeah in primary
school i don't remember going i probably
i could have gone to lessons when i was
a kid i don't remember yeah yeah that's
um anyway guys
yeah anyway guys rant over so um a bit
of a different episode for you guys
today i hope you enjoyed it as always
guys patreon.com come see us on thursday
um and let's have another laugh if you
want double the episodes guys and um
yeah love love
[Music]
you